limítrofe con Venezuela al catatumbo
alberga la mayor superficie de cultivo
ilegal de coca en el mundo José del
Carmen abril es uno de los cientos de
miles de personas que abandonaron la
agricultura tradicional para cultivar
estas hojas verdes en la coca para los
campesinos desde el 86 para acá se
convirtió en el gobierno que nunca ha
venido por acá y ustedes preguntarán por
qué o el gobierno pregunta por qué Por
qué la coca es con la que se ha llevado
a hacer escuelas a ser puestos de salud
carreteras hacer la vivienda en el país
que más produce la pasta que sirve para
el polvo blanco que consumen en Estados
Unidos y Europa los recolectores son El
eslabón más débil de la cadena el
presidente izquierdista Gustavo Petro
dijo querer cambiar la política
antidrogas a nivel nacional e
internacional pero los campesinos
cocaleros piden todavía más apoyo para
la transición a otras economías y menos
criminalización varias oportunidades por
ser recolector de Coca nos nos tildan de
de guerrilleros de narcotraficantes de
bueno de ser un delincuente aquí en
Colombia el gobierno nos persigue muchas
veces nos han llevado presos en
diciembre el gobierno se comprometió a
dejar de perseguir a los campesinos con
menos de dos hectáreas de coca y la
semana pasada la Policía Nacional fijo
su meta de erradicación de cultivos
ilícitos para 2023 en 20 mil hectáreas
una reducción de 60% con respecto al
objetivo para 2022 las autoridades
buscarán este año atacar los eslabones
más lucrativos del negocio y luchar
contra la violencia recrudecida por Las
Guerras entre grupos armados y
narcotraficantes